last time we talked I think you
mentioned to me I have two kids you have
two kids I have yet twelve and nine
twelve and nine that's exactly like me
twelve and nine really and well 11 and 9
but about to be 12
yes weird weird age because he asked me
to buy Axe body spray
oh the 12 year olds a boy yeah so he
wanted to buy ax and I said no we don't
you know we're not wearing tank tops and
we're not buying Axe body spray
yeah it feels like policy I establish
yeah that is good for you that you you
held the line on Axe body spray okay
weird what see what's your son like
what's he you know I'm trying to think
cuz my my boy is much younger than that
what's well I mean they're the kids that
go to school are also polite and nice
that I actually had my wife and her
friends are calling me dream killer
because I told him there was no Santa
Claus I had to do it you told him there
was no Santa Claus he was getting too
old I the last time I was here you were
very sick but I mentioned that I found
out my grandfather murdered a guy I
don't know if you remember that's right
yeah we Cory Europe
your grandfather murdered someone in
what country in Mexico Mexico and then
had to leave had to flee that's why he
came here
yeah because he murdered a guy yeah
which is great for me is is really
working out but uh when my son's like
dad hate the cookies we come from
murderers you can't he needs to grow up
is what you say he was aging out of it
and I did such a good job selling it to
and that was part of the problem is that
I would take a bite out of the cookies
Avantika
you know okay and I had chopped to care
it I moved the fireplace great and I'd
move some of the ashes right and then my
dad did this and I'd carried on the
tradition I would shake it like a jingle
bell and then I'd say ho ho ho and I'd
slam the door and then at three years
old and five years old they'd come
running out in footie pajamas oh my god
he's here he came he came he came right
when they're ninth
eleven you're like come on you idiots
[Laughter]
[Applause]
leaves through the door
yeah I understand yeah and so I told he
already knew that there wasn't a tooth
fairy or an Easter Bunny okay how do you
find out about that well he found the
teeth what when you're around us he when
you have kids and your kid loses his
first tooth you're not some soulless
jerk that just throws it in the trash we
kept it my wife goes oh my god this is
so weird
and we just what do we do we put it in a
jewelry box and then we put down then
another tooth can we nested it right
there with it and then nine years and
two kids later you're two crazy people
with twenty human teeth in a box
ours are in an envelope yeah yeah we're
we're much less sentimental we're
keeping them but they're an envelope I
don't think you're gonna mail it yeah
yeah it's like some raffia yeah yeah you
keep your mouth shut
yeah
it is like you open it you expect to see
cut diamonds and oh my god yeah that's
how they should find out you should mail
them the envelope so wait so you're
saying that your son
I mean did he find he was looking for a
stapler remover which is an honor four
legged nine-year-old you know it's a
dangerous piece of office equipment yeah
we went from the high of looking for a
stapler remover to finding his teeth and
he walked out just white as a ghost he
walked out and looks at me and my wife
because I think at first it didn't dawn
on him that they were his teeth the
Easter Bunny that's always felt to me
like that's the toughest one to sell
that there's a nine foot tall bunny
that's running around from people does
not take a beautiful mind to deduce that
this is not happening like I keep the
baskets above the garage refrigerator
like everything's just strewn about yeah
everything's all get to faerie we really
sell that I'm just glad that that's
behind me right it's you're living a lie
and it cost a fortune
like we'd forget half the time and my
wife and say what do you got you got I
got any why he lost another tooth I was
like I only got ten bucks I'm not giving
him ten bucks yeah you know you just end
up giving in ten bucks because you're
lazy and then he walks out like he won
Super Lotto you know and the next time
we forget and you know he's disappointed
because we walks out because look tooth
fairy just left me a dollar thirty six
two stories mad at you yeah Easter Bunny
yeah yeah but he's cool he's aw he's
into like he gets good grades my wife's
Korean so he'd better
[Laughter]